what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu right
now i'm actually on my way to see the
premiere for venom let there be carnage
so it would be appropriate that i would
talk about venom and of course
spider-man today today we have details
on a new scene from spider-man no way
home some of you may have heard about
this yesterday but i can personally tell
you that it fits into a real plot leak
which i am going to talk about today
you've probably heard me talk about this
plot leak that has been proven to be
real this scene is actually a part of
this and in this video i'm going to be
connecting the two together then i'm
going to talk about the spider-man
universe as a whole and talk about how
it's expanding how a new movie for the
spider-verse is going to be coming out
soon and how spider-man will most likely
be in that film as well and not to
mention it does look like the venom
universe and the mcu could be one they
could actually be the same universe and
apparently we're going to figure that
out and venom let there be carnage so a
lot to break down today and if you are
new and you want to stay up to date on
all spider-man venom and mcu news be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so this
scene is actually a very particular
scene from the actual official trailer
that we got and it's interesting because
people seemingly knew about this scene
before we got the actual trailer before
the actual trailer was even leaked
because a few days before we got that
leaked trailer but there were some
people doing designs of this scene
before the trailer even came out and now
it makes sense considering the fact that
we're getting a little bit more details
about this scene somehow before this
scene got out and now we're finding out
even more about it the scene is where
peter and doctor strange are seemingly
fighting each other we all know of the
scene where peter parker and doctor
strange are on the train strange
multiplies the train and peter looks
around kind of in shock now in the
trailer they seemingly begin to fight
when dr strange says the problem is
peter is trying to live a double life we
then see strange kind of knock the
astral projection of peter out of his
body kind of knocks his soul out of his
body and the reason that he seemingly
does this is because of what is in his
hand if you look closely at the left
hand of spider-man you can see that
peter parker is holding some type of
artifact it seems to be in the shape of
a cube and it does seem to be very
important important enough for peter to
try and take and strange to go after him
for now this report of this scene is
coming from the cosmiccircus.com
and this is what they have to say about
this cube artifact they state that the
cube's nature is actually original to
the mcu and not something that has been
seen in marvel comics before however
they go on to say but more on that
another time not giving any more details
about the cube fortunately i do know a
little more about the cube which i'll
talk about in a bit but let's finish
this scene first the cosmic circus goes
on to say that they have exclusively
learned that during this chase sequence
there will be a point when steven will
actually use the cloak of levitation to
try and trap spider-man during this
chase and again more on the chase in
just a bit but they go on to say so by
technicality peter will don strange's
iconic cloak at one point during the
chase sequence much like we saw his
varying counterpart and what if however
instead of the cloak teaming up with
spider-man like it did in what if it's
actually going to be going against him
and still going to be strangers since
strange is alive and not a zombie and
apparently he is going to use this to
hold peter in place and bring him back
to him in order to confront him directly
so that'll be a cool scene to see we
kind of saw the cloak fight on its own
during what if but now we're going to
see it happen live action against
spider-man now as far as the cube is
concerned and as far as the so-called
chase is concerned here's what we know
peter in the beginning of no way home is
going through all the repercussions of
mysterio's lie mysterio of course said
that peter parker attacked him and then
killed him we know that peter is going
to go to court in the beginning of no
way home and we know that things get
hard enough and rough enough that he
ends up going to doctor strange and asks
doctor strange to cast a spell to make
everybody forget that he's spider-man
this is something that a plot league
told us months before the first trailer
even came out and here's what the plot
leak has to say about the rest of it
about the cube and the chase the plot
leak says that the spell goes wrong and
we do hear doctor strange telling peter
that he is tampering with the spell as
he's doing it in the trailer so the
spell goes wrong and it ends up bringing
five spider villains from other
dimensions to the mcu and of course we
know which ones they are doc guac the
green goblin electro sandman and the
lizard norman osborne is talking to the
others asking what is the last thing
they remember and they all say that
spider-man killed them although sandman
didn't die and he left on good terms
with peter parker so i wonder if he's
taken a little bit before the good stuff
happens with peter but basically they're
being kept in some sort of a magical
prison that doctor strange is holding
them in doctor strange wants to send
them back to where they came from
however the villains argue that if they
do that they are just going to die
they're going to go back to that same
exact point where they died and die so
peter doesn't want to send them back
because he feels bad that another
spider-man kills them and here's where
things get important it says that norman
osborne manipulates peter parker into
releasing the villains and from here
peter fights strange and breaks the key
which is a cube that held them captive
and the villains are now free so this
scene that we are apparently going to be
seeing right here is this scene the
scene where dr strange kind of does that
astral projection knock where peter is
holding the cube is most likely this
scene now it does say that when the
villains break out they start to
terrorize new york and one would think
that if they got loose in the sanctum
strange could have some type of
procedure or measurements in place for
defensive procedures to stop them
somehow from getting outside of the
sanctum however since the key is
apparently what is holding the villains
captive it is a possibility that they
could actually be inside of that cube
because they are outside in this scene
and if the cube breaks here and it's
holding them that could be how they get
released into new york we'll have to
wait and see but it does right now seem
like the key is some sort of a prison or
the key to a prison and it seemingly is
going to be an mcu proprietary artifact
so i am very curious to learn more about
this and i'm also very curious to see
how this universe connects to venom
because according to some recent reports
the venom sony universe and the
spider-man mcu universe are the same
they're not different now this is kind
of contradictory to what we knew in the
past but keep in mind that sony did just
change their universe's name it used to
be the sp umc the sony picture universe
of marvel characters but now it's simply
sony spider-man universe why the change
right before spider-man no way home and
venom let there be carnage come out this
has been expected for a while but now
it's getting a little bit more real the
closer we get to venom let there be
carnage and according to a recent report
from deadline on their hero nation
podcast they said two things firstly
venom is reportedly expected to connect
to the mcu version of spider-man and
secondly a new sinister six film is
apparently going to be off the ground
pretty soon at least that is sony's goal
now as far as connecting venom to
spider-man there are rumors about a
post-credit scene in venom let there be
carnage that does exactly this connect
venom to the mcu that will obviously
have to wait until we actually see the
post-credits scene but as far as a
sinister six film is concerned we do
know that they tried to make one in the
past before they had a director planned
and everything for it however it didn't
get made but recently back in 2019
spider-man franchise producer amy pascal
teased the eventual formation of the
sinister six telling us that all the
villains have actually been introduced
in the last two spider-man films
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home now since we are getting a
different sinister six in spider-man no
way home those plans could have changed
a little bit but it does still look like
an actual movie just focusing on the
sinister six is going to happen
eventually at some point in time which
makes us wonder are these villains going
to die in this universe are they going
to go free what exactly is going to
happen we'll have to wait till no way
home to find that out but this could
come as good news to some fans because a
lot of people want to see just one peter
parker tom holland's peter parker go up
against the sinister six without any
help from the other two spider-man or
doctor strange or anybody else a lot of
people really just want to see
spider-man on his own for once but let
me know what you think about all of this
in the comments down below what do you
think about this scene and are you
excited for the venomverse to finally
connect to the mcu let me know and don't
forget to like this video and of course
for live updates you can always follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you